welcome to CBS this morning we begin
with a very unsettled were world where
tensions over the u.s. killing of Iran's
most important general are escalating to
new heights today these are the scenes
this morning where police in Iran's
capitals say millions of people attended
a funeral for Qasem Soleimani this
morning a sea of mourners surrounded the
vehicle carrying his casket soleimani
successor is publicly vowing revenge
this morning more than 3,000 additional
US troops are heading right now for the
Middle East President Trump is standing
by his vow to target up to 52
significant sites inside Iran if
necessary he told reporters on Air Force
One they're allowed to kill our people
and we're not allowed to touch their
cultural sites it doesn't work that way
iran's Foreign Minister says any such
attack would be a war crime Elizabeth
Palmer is in Tehran Iran's capital and
was amid the massive crowd attending the
generals funeral as Elizabeth how is
Iran responding well very emotionally
we're starting to see the fallout from
Qasem Soleimani
assassination first of all politically
Iran has announced that it's going to
virtually pull out of what is already a
very tattered nuclear deal it said it's
just going to go back to enriching as
much uranium as it chooses meanwhile
Qasem Soleimani body is on a kind of an
honor tour procession of various cities
here in Iran and today he arrived in
Tehran
not since the death of Ayatollah
Khomeini 30 years ago have crowds like
this turned out to mourn early in life
Qasem Soleimani was celebrated as a
military commander in death he's being
saluted as a hero and a martyr Allah
Iran's current supreme leader Ayatollah
Khomeini wept as he led the prayer
service the two men had worked closely
to steer Iran's foreign policy and
extend its influence in the Middle East
this is not just a mourning procession
it's a political message designed to
demonstrate that all Iranians are united
in anger and an outrage again time the
United States there's been a response to
president Trump's threat to strike
Iran's cultural sites
foreign minister Javad Zarif tweeted
that attacking them would be a war crime
in Iran's Parliament lawmakers chanted
the by now wrote death to America and
House leader Ally Lara Jean II addressed
the us directly you ought to know he
said that this deed will bring painful
consequences we don't know yet if that
means military reprisals but if so
they're likely to involve this man
Hassan Nasrallah
and his followers in Hezbollah Iran's
proxy fighting force in Lebanon the US
military killed Sony money said
nasrallah and it will pay though he
specified Americans citizens would not
be targeted it lives what can you tell
us about the man who was replaced
Soleimani in Iran he is another
Revolutionary Guards commander very
senior one his name is s mild agon
Connie he's been on the US sanctions
list since 2012 because he's believed to
among other things have overseen the
distribution of weapons and money to
Iran's proxies overseas he's a shadowy
figure it remains to be seen whether he
has the strategic strength that
Soleimani did he probably doesn't have
Soleimani 'he's by now mythic charisma
all right Elizabeth Palmer the world is
watching we thank you reporting live
from Tehran
you